welcome to the podcast everybody welcome
back to the podcast everybody my name is
Julian and I didn't have sponsors ready
when do you introduce yourself in the
podcast I don't know it's been like a
month it's been so long since we
podcasted probably like two months what
do you think how long do you think yeah
definitely two months Julian it's been a
while
I really should check up on the skin to
get all the news in the daily email
newsletter sent to my email completely
for free with all the top stories that I
need to know so I can be the most
educated person just in basic
conversation not in general just come
off educated that's the goal go to the
skin that's th esk I am calm / Jenna
Julian and to email click Subscribe
you're done and you enter to win a big
old gift card check that out also guys
honey book it is such an amazing service
to help you freelancers or small
business owners whether you're a graphic
designer
you're an animator photographer whatever
honey book is the all-in-one business
management platform that takes care of
all the boring stuff so you can be
creative go - honey book HOA any ybo
ok.com
/ annejulien actually it's just calm and
then use promo code generally for 50%
off your first year of honey book it
applies whether you're doing a monthly
or annual payment actually a super cool
service for independent people
independent small business owners also
guys stitch fix I don't know if you've
noticed but in the vlogs and in my life
and on stream I've been wearing some new
things lately you know why cuz stitch
fix hooked me up it is a service where
you get your own lot of your online own
a personal stylist right who what oh
thank you going
it's stylist right stylist is the pen
use on a phone it's stylist stylist with
Atias stylist no I get your own personal
stylist no it's a stylist basically they
send you clothes that they know you'll
like so you don't have to go shopping
for yourself it's very cool go
- stitch fix STI TCH fi XCOM / Jun and
Julian the signup process is actually
really fun you answer a bunch of
questions about your style preferences
and then BAM they send you clothes and
whatever you don't like you send back
don't pay for it yeah I'm laughing
Julian because he was doing this while
we were setting up for the podcast oh my
god I think this is the first time
focused himself in the monitor so he's
just I don't think you're gonna need to
take a picture once this video Saudis
and staring at it is that you mumble
Rafa who's the handsome boy in the
mirror get the dog oh mama we've
recorded like 230 episodes I can't
figure out what he's staring at but I'm
pretty sure it's him yeah it's like
angled to the right of the monitor the
monitors like right behind our camera
who's that my bull is that you okay
goodnight weird it's weird like he's
seen a million monitors a million camera
monitors million million mirrors and
this is the time he decides to look well
you know when he was a puppy the first
time I ever heard him bark it was at his
own reflection that was his first bark
it's like the first time I ever heard
him bark because I lived in Boston so
you have basements and they have like
those little windows like right at
ground level you know and he walked
right up to one of those little windows
and just saw himself for the first time
and he went and that was the first time
you heard him ever heard him well that's
so funny who was it the other day Oh
Joleen
Jeff Stark was watching TV she literally
watches TV I could not believe it so
we're we're gonna talk about Julian's
birthday happy birthday by the way
you don't have to say that anymore it's
pass
everything thank you we celebrated for
like the whole weekend and all of our
friends came and it was such a good time
we'll talk about that but so they all
went to go get tattoos and they drove
out to like Orange County okay what
we're not gonna do is scream and so I
was like it's kind of a long day for all
the dogs because Jolene was with us too
yeah for all of them just stay at the
house by themselves like they're okay
but you know there used to be 24/7 so
it's kind of a long day for them and
then with all like all the people
staying here you know it's kind of a lot
so I don't want to leave them so I
volunteered to stay back and dog sit for
the day and so I was like I took a
shower and you know did my hair and
they're all hanging out with me or
having a good time so I turned on the TV
show alone which is my favorite show
where you talk about oh my god I cannot
believe I've been living without that
show I love it but so I turned on alone
and I had them all like in the bed and I
laid down for a minute just to hang out
with them yeah and Jolene is like
literally watching the show like she has
like she's a Chuck she's a chihuahua pug
pushed-in she has these like big green
yellow brown human looking eyes like she
looks like a person and she has this
long little wiggle body and huge bat
ears and she's just watching the TV and
I could not believe it and like if she
heard like a wolf you know there's
wolves in that show something like that
she's cool but well why don't you just
turn and look at it like I feel like
that he's staring at himself again like
these guys don't really do that you know
if they hear like the thing that gets
them going is if they hear a dog like
collar the leash the sound of like the
old jingle would be also any any sort of
rustling in the bushes or the fences
they assume it's a squirrel so they
that's like sets them off if I'm talking
about going on a TV they'll hear the
sound of like rustling in bushes I've
heard peach and Kermit go like this but
there's no interest in watching it it's
no no no get them going
the our dogs do not look at the TV and
like you know some dogs will watch birds
and stuff
that our dogs have no interest in that
Jolene will watch TV I think they're
their only the only time I've ever seen
them engaged in TV is when we play
videos of them howling and they think
it's other dogs
well it's just this sounds like the
sound but yeah they don't watch they do
not watch
it's like Jenner's sitting on the bed
watching the TV and I was like are you
watching this right now
yeah it was crazy but I've heard people
have pets like I've heard a lot of
people have pets that watch TV they just
get it they're just I was martyr
yeah but like peach is smart and she
doesn't watch TV maybe she's like I read
well it's funny too because you'd think
like right if you had to hypothesize
what kind of dogs would like watching TV
you'd think a sighthound would like to
watch TV it'd be visually engaging for
them that's not I get I think they're
lazy overpowers any sighthound ability
that they have yeah it's so hilarious
though because they are such little
loafs and like everyone's like Oh any
time we meet someone while we're walking
them they're like oh my god that dog is
so fast you must need a run so much they
probably need require no dude they're
little laziest dog in the world they
want like one or two good zoomies they
appreciate they appreciate a walk like
every dog they want to run fast maybe
once a day for like 1/2 Sprint's done
and then they want to sit on the couch
and like cry well no that's just Kermit
that is not the beam cry that is not the
breed that's just Kermit scream ok but
anyway yeah they're misunderstood you
guys are not athletes you're loafs this
guy's been crying non-stop for like days
it's just having a Cushing's day he's
having her Cushing's week he's having a
coaching's like my guy anyway we had a
really awesome weekend so uh I've never
done the whole like week-long birthday
celebration before I was very cool it
was very fun you were amazing and
wonderful and the best friend I could
ever ask for it I loved being friends
such good friends it was funny
explaining to like my parents well you
know what I think I was might talking
about dad and I was explaining what I
was doing for my birth
so what are you doing I was like um I
mean have some friends come come into
town and hang out and he's like all cool
like who and he started named some of my
friends he thought it might be no we met
most of them online
and it's just like so crazy yeah like
you came with them yeah do you talk to
them yeah for like 10 hours at a time
we're like on the phone pretty much
every night yeah but it's like and then
they all came to town we had people come
from all over it was it was really
wonderful boy brought to peppers and
like chili powder mm-hmm and we'll got
you a pair of Crocs for your birthday
well doesn't blows my main piece well
knows how to do it to him he does know
how to do it then we had Caleb come from
Mississippi mm-hmm Lexi sort of local
and then we had Chris and Cheer Chris
and Shan are our main squeezes well it's
been three years in a row now that we've
spent either your birthday or Shannon's
birthday which is just before your
birthday with Chris and Jen basically
spread spent some time in April with
them pretty great three years ago we
were in Vegas which was such a fun time
and I like that's one of my favorite
vlogs cuz just the memories attached to
it mm-hmm
we surprised her mm-hmm then last year
they came up we all got tattoos you got
your chef Jennifer dinosaur tattoo
bowling and then this year they came and
stayed at our house and it was like
hotel J&J it Louise literally like we
were this close to having someone sleep
right there um but what we did was we
just like turn everything into a bedroom
we got this like little fold-out bed off
of Amazon put it in the like our little
gym and then we put our air mattress in
the stream room and two people laid on
the couch and Chris and Shannon I had
hotel room so I was like you guys are
more than welcome to let go you know
have your own bathroom we're like
whatever everyone's like no knowledge
upon the couch I mean I don't blame him
if I was them I would want to be part of
everything - I don't wanna leave to go
to hotel and we had 8000 bagels here you
know a lot of bagels and a lot of chips
and a lot of alcohol we did something
very cool with post mates post mice is
in the sponsor this week but we decided
it was Lexi's idea we were all pretty
hungover
it was tired it was Sunday we're
days are cheat day even though we've
been eating and drinking alcohol all
weekend but Sunday's usually the day
where Julien and I get our favorite food
so we did post look hot look everyone
get your favorite food and we'll eat it
all together yeah and then all got
delivered and it was this mess of food
and we watched Game of Thrones it was
like all the way from the beginning to
the end it was a great weekend it was
really fun and then when everyone left
you have that like terrible sadness an
empty house and you're just like my
friends are gone but it's it's a good
thing it was hard to say goodbye though
yeah but it's a good thing that we have
friends that we don't want to say
goodbye there it's true you know that's
a good thing oh yeah you're really lucky
I mean I said in my video when we were
making your birthday cake which was
delicious by the way it came out really
good
but who's very good I forgot to do
candles while everyone was here so I did
it on your actual birthday please
forgive me but we did eat it it was
really good I don't know like I think
it's as you get older you just
appreciate people's time you know and
like what it means to see them and spend
time with them and that's like the best
birthday present you could get is just
getting to hang out with someone that
you care about and that cares about you
that's how I feel that's how it felt
this year for sure yeah and what was
cool is like the last time most of this
group hung out together was at twitchcon
and technically that's work and so
you're at work but you're at a con and
so you do get to spend time that you
normally wouldn't spend you're you're
grabbing dinner together you're drinking
a little bit together you know you're in
the same proximity and so I think that
was like we we left that we were like
man we really appreciated the time we
just got with all of our friends that we
don't ever see and so when you were like
what do you wonder if every day I was
like I want to see them all again I
wanted to do twitchcon again we just
sans the con yeah and we did it and it
was great it was great yeah Caleb got me
a tractor it's out back no he didn't he
got me some horses they're all packed no
he did it the horses are not in the best
are in the back
on this marble marble wait why are
you.why don't wake him up wanna penance
I was gonna wake him up first okay all
right
you can ask him Bob what can I pay you
okay he opened his eyes not even pendant
yeah he's been sleeping with me like
every night are you jealous well let's
talk about alone I want you to tell us
about alone
I love alone alone is a great show
it's [ __ ] so yeah well so I really
like shows like that like I the wheel
this boy I really like I'm always
looking for shows like that I really
like outdoor stuff I feel like I like to
watch the content that is the life that
I'd like to live you know like alternate
how a lot of people watch like Real
Housewives and like the Kardashians and
they're like man that just seems really
cool like I really you know I've admired
their lifestyle or whatever for me
that's like watching it started with
mountain men which in my opinion is way
to overproduce
these boys that just like doing regular
[ __ ] and it's like due to to to to to to
to Eustace must plant his kale before
this frost comes in or else he won't
have a crop in the spring do 2 2 2 2 I'm
like all right you know but let's take
it down like a thousand [ __ ] not but
that's that's like the nor the norm for
those types of shows so I was watching
that and watched the whole first season
really liked it and I was like I was on
Hulu because there was only one season
of mountain men on Hulu so I bought the
other ones on YouTube because I really
even though it's over produced in a
little dramatic I don't really like to
the good character season one follows
three grown men who are mountain men one
lives in Montana he's adorable his
name's Tom he's got a wife their whole
season revolves around this grizzly bear
that may or may not be somewhere around
their property it's very dramatic the
other guy's name is Eustace he lives in
North Carolina and he lives off his land
which is interesting to watch because
unlike Tom who's just maybe or maybe not
fighting a bear
he is only living off his land
so like the hunting and you know all the
heat at one point gets a cold and walks
into the woods and starts eating some
weird root it's pretty nasty
and then my guy Marty who lives in
Alaska and he's a fur trapper so he
travels like in a bush plane and he's on
the dollar [ __ ] nowhere no no that
season too I'm a Marty Oh Marty's on the
plane Marty he mounts his rifle on the
wing of the plane when he flies it he
makes okay I'm gonna say something
controversial I know Moshe I'll have no
[ __ ] clue what I'm talking about
but my guy Marty in Alaska makes those
other two look like a bunch of [ __ ]
like Marty is flying a bush plane into
the middle of nowhere [ __ ] is
controversial I'm just ready they're all
wonderful no they're all wonderful but
he basically it's just like does the
most crazy she at one point ran over his
glasses with his snowmobile and he has
no like navigation instruments on his
bush plane
so it's always like the it's it's all
analog there's not a screen in there
yeah it's like yeah he only flies by
sight and he's got these big thick like
coke bottle glasses and he runs over him
with his snowmobile and then he's like
oh no lost my glasses eh hopefully I
have like a backup pair in my in my bush
plane he's like I don't know I can't
find him I'm just gonna have to fly
without him like it's just so [ __ ]
insane like they they cannot over
produce Marty because it's not possible
that sounds kind of well no one else is
flying up there I was gonna say it
sounds irresponsible for other people if
you're flying blind well here's the
thing like in Alaska that's how a lot of
people get you hear about those one
passenger plane crashes often because it
just is something that happens for
people that live in that state not in
the cities and they get around you know
to do their jobs and he's a trapper so
he has to go to the place where he can
trap animals and he is his big old tires
during the spring and summer yeah so you
can just land in the middle of a field
it's crazy so I watched that I really
liked it and then before I looked it up
the second season on YouTube I saw a
show called alone and our trainer
actually was yeah we he told us about it
yeah but I had seen it and it was one of
the ones I considered so the next day I
put on alone
and it's [ __ ] spectacular the the
concept is I think there's 10 the first
season is men but in the second season
they have men and women and they send
them to what Vancouver Island it's just
the like it's a [ __ ] cold rainforest
like it is so wet it rained I think it
said 15 out of the first 19 days that it
rained so all these people coming in are
like
ex-military you know they're cops they
like people that have good understanding
of survival skills or they do it like by
trade and they teach other people like
that's how they earn their living and
you see them just struggle to even make
a fire in that environment and it is so
devastating but the concept is they send
ten survival experts to Vancouver Island
which is just one hellish nightmare of a
place to survive and whoever lasts the
longest wins and they're completely
alone there is no camera crew they have
to like essentially vlog their
experience themselves they are equipped
with a satellite phone so whenever they
want to tap out they can call and a lot
of them do that because of wildlife
emergencies so they're getting charged
by a bear there's wolves there's that
kind of [ __ ] you know for the first
couple days their shelters are very
basic you know they have a lean-to or
like a tarp or whatever they can just
set up to get out of the rain to stay
dry to maybe make a fire but that
certainly does not deter a bear from
coming up to you just because you're
completely exposed
but the person who lasts the longest
wins $500,000 but like what a genius
concepts let's throw them all out there
with their own cameras let's see if they
can survive if they can then they're
gonna go [ __ ] nuts from being alone
for that long they have to film it we'll
just be on Carla in case they need help
send us your footage here here you go
editor but bump bump alone make us money
it's a really cool show yeah they don't
give them anything either they're
allowed 10 survival items when they go
out there most people use like a knife a
tarp or rope but they they don't over
edit it and they don't over produce it
like they leave a lot of the moments in
there of people starting
to really sit with the fact that they're
missing their loved ones and that they
have no one to be with or speak to or
anything like that and I really
appreciate those moments of honesty that
they don't cut out you know yeah you're
right I mean it's impossible to like Wow
filming produce anything because there
is no one they have a literal the
lugging around these huge Pelican cases
with I'm assuming just heaps of
batteries because there's no electricity
out there so they're charging you know
that they have to power these cameras
and but yeah I like how they let it
breathe in the editing they really do
they look because there's a lot of
moments where you get and I think one of
the most interesting parts of that show
isn't the physical survival but it's the
mental survival and you start to really
get a good insight to certain people and
and how it just takes a toll and them
and what it makes them think about and
some they're like they start talking
about their life and they're telling
stories and they're like questioning
certain decisions and they're like
reflecting and it's just it's very
interesting there's nothing to distract
you there's no phone there's no friends
there's no oh I'll just go watch a show
for a little bit I'll go do this it's
like you're really forced to look at
your life non-stop and you can't hide
from it and you can't distract yourself
from it and it starts so like really
kind of break people a little bit but in
a good way and all of them are looking
forward to that experience and most of
them get that yeah they all signed up
for pretty much exactly I told you like
one of my favorite shots in season one
is like the guy's just standing in front
of a tree for way too long like you're
just getting like is he okay like it's
something going on yeah these are
standing there in dead silence Hey
did I scare you oh sorry I'm fine it's
day 15 how's it going like you know
you're starting to get like a little
loopy dude you have no one to talk to
why are you screaming at me I just put
you down because you wanted to get down
now you want to get back up it's also
funny like you wouldn't last a day alone
Kermit who would cry if a Kermit cries
in a forest and no one's there to
control his crying what happens well
it's also funny like you mentioned that
guy I forget his do you remember his
name the guy you're talking about Alan
Alan so like he's a great example of
someone who's not only like making the
best of a shitty situation but he is
just a natural entertaining
guy like he's funny he's charismatic
he's avoid Julian always like I wasn't a
super fan of his in the beginning but
then I realized he's a pretty good
vlogger like I like him yeah I would
watch he's a vlogger and it's funny
because like if you strip everything
down from like a vlogger you strip all
the extraneous factors all the location
the family the friends the money the
circumstances all that down all you have
is the camera that's what this show it's
really it's like who can make an
entertaining like story really about
what's happening to you Wow in the wild
and some of these people are like nasty
some these people are just very
surprisingly entertaining in situations
where you're like how the [ __ ] can you
listen okay so if you were because I've
always wondered right like we watch
Survivor when you watch a show like that
like how would I do right how would I
first of all I wouldn't be able to make
a fire like if those survival experts
are struggling to make a fire I mean
nobody making crash-and-burn
yeah but if I was in a scenario where I
could make a fire it was dry it was not
that terrible awful environment maybe
I'd be okay but I feel like if there was
no camera it would be a lot harder
because it does give you a tangible task
as boredom really starts to set in
filming and talking to a camera like
there's so much to be learned in those
shows half of them they're giving you
tutorials and explaining to you all
their survival knowledge right it's
really exciting to watch but that kills
a lot of time like doing that alright it
kills a lot of time and it also keeps
you like you wake up and you have
something to do every day know its
purpose if the camera was not there I
feel like it would be a lot more of like
a crushing alone feeling yeah there's
nothing going on right step on the
hermit don't step on the audio equipment
karmak don't do that I feel like though
if I was in that situation like it would
be really comforting to know that you
have something to do well then I think a
lot of them excel at it and don't do
okay because it is someone to talk to in
theory even though you're talking to
yourself but how many times have you
blogged alone and it feels like just a
little better because you're not
well yeah it's it's sort of like
audience yeah it's like venting to a
friend or you know some people like it's
my therapy I get to talk to a camera or
whatever it's that sort of concept but
um like when some of them start to lose
it they're hungry they're thirsty
sleep-deprived they start talking I
remember one of them was like I got I
woke up this morning and I was really
excited to start talking to the camera
because I feel like you guys are my
friend at this point and I was like damn
like that's this guy probably in his
life never would have said that about a
camera and talking to a camera because
that's just such a weird thing but
you're right like it becomes their their
rock a little bit I just feel like if I
did something like that I feel like a
lot of people would be genuinely
concerned about my well-being but I
would be just fine because I really am
that [ __ ] out of control when I'm by
myself you know what I'm saying so I
have a question for you what what would
you do better at a social game like
survivor or an anti-social game I would
like alone well first of all I would do
amazing it both I'm kidding
I would probably quit alone you don't
think you would do well I think I would
do okay like I grew up doing that stuff
that's what I'm saying but I think I
would do okay on either but I like the
idea of the that location with the
wolves and with the bear sure the
wildlife is I would be lying to myself
if I said I couldn't excel in that
environment
I just cannot because fearing for your
life from animals without any level of
protection is really terrifying I don't
know how much they were told
going into the experience but if I was
signing up to do a survivalist show like
that and I read anywhere that there's
gonna be like literal wolves and bears
like right next to my campsite I'm not
doing that I'm not even entering that
scenario yeah I mean there's a lot of
things you can do to deter them and to
protect yourself but when push comes to
shove if a bear decides that he wants
what you have or he's hungry or he's not
scared of you like that's it's game over
you're not she's gonna fight a bear good
luck but um I think I would do better in
a social situation like survivor yeah
well because I feel like the I think
statistically the people who win
survivor the most are like middle-aged
women but in theory the people that do
the
based on the show are like the most
well-rounded people so you have people
that are relatively athletic that you
know work relatively hard around camp
they don't make other people depend on
them
that they're relatively good socially
like just a your person that high school
player yes but you're not you know
excelling in athleticism you're not
excelling like in the social game then
yeah but if you're the most well-rounded
person they tend to do the best I would
say that's you I mean you're you're
well-rounded you you're why I would say
you're more athletic than most people
but you're also I don't know the social
thing is interesting right because it's
like socially you're good with people
anyone you meet like likes you it's hard
not to like you but at the same time you
do I feel like possess a certain level
of skill when it comes to like hearing
people and like really listening you
know I mean a lot of people went to
college folks well a lot of people don't
do that and don't know how to do that so
I think that I think if there was ever
like an actual advantage in your game it
would be that yeah but I do think that I
would do much better in a situation
where there's other people because it
does give you that sense of security if
you're in a camp with a lot of other
people and there are any you know
wildlife things that can come and attack
you in your sleep they're way less
likely to do so if there's 13 of you
then if there's one of you yeah it's
crazy to think that they're actually
alone yeah I can't fall any of those
people for deciding to leave after one
scary experience with a bear or a wolf
like I feel for that you know yeah
because it's where we live
we're the top of the food chain but when
you get in an experience where you are
not the top of the food chain that's
enough to be like I'm out of here
because a lot of those people are saying
to you know $500,000 is a lot of money
that's all that's life-changing money
for those people yeah like all of them
on that show it was no like rogue
millionaire being like I just got some
and improved like it was enough for all
of them whereas the wheel was no prize
because there was no prize it was just
to see if they give it yeah it was
life-changing money for those anyone on
the show yeah and all of them that we're
starting to quit because of the
wildlife things we're just like $500,000
you know would do so much for my family
would change my life change our [ __ ]
life but they also need me home like
what good is any of that if they don't
have their dad or their uncle or their
brother not worth it yeah sorry you know
it's not worth dying for no but it is
probably the only show that I've seen
where people were actually fearing for
their lives yeah which I don't know how
like how how they I know they sign away
their life to be on any reality show
really but like maybe that's my film in
Canada I'm sorry the loophole or so oh
my god yeah and we're not exaggerating
like there are scenes were guys get
actually like you know like intimidated
and aggressed no that's not a word
what's the word edged charged like a
chart one guy got charged by bear I'm
sorry
- there's like wolves there's it's
gnarly it's like really [ __ ] gnarly
here I love it though yeah what it's
gnarly but it's not as gnarly he's doing
I was waiting all the business work that
comes along with being an independent
small business owner or graphic designer
like honey book okay honey book does all
the work for you if you are a graphic
designer or a photographer you picked up
a camera and you turned out turns out
you're pretty good with it and you want
to make a business out of it you start a
website then you realize oh man there's
a lot of business things that I don't
know how to do I just know how to do
these pictures really [ __ ] well and I
know I can make money off of it well
honey book is there to help you run your
business they make it really easy to
streamline your workflow and get your
your whole entire operation up and
running with a bunch of tools like
calendar management tools branded
brochures proposals contracts contracts
the most just annoying thing to ever
have to deal with they can even generate
signatures invoices and you can get paid
faster with in all their online honey
book system it's actually super super
nice it's it's like the small man's the
little man's a little guy's tool to
become successful little guy or gals
tool to become successful
and the payment is flexible so you don't
have to pay by the year if that's not
for you you don't have to pay for the
month that's not for you you can figure
out a payment plan that works for you it
can be $20 a month or $200 for a whole
year and you get 50% off monthly or
annually when you use code Jen and
Julian when you go to honey book hom ey
Bo okay calm and signup use our promo
code generally and let us know you like
it you can kind of cancel if you don't
like it do it monthly cancel no big deal
but give it a shot
also guys the skim what a cool product
that is it's an email newsletter that
comes to your inbox every morning with
the top news stories and bits of
information that is important that you
know to go out into the world and be
educated and it's completely free what's
great about skim is it's not jumbled up
it's not there's no big pictures and ads
and all that sort of stuff that you have
to sort through it's very simple it's
right there for you on your email and
it's readable it's just it's like the
cliffnotes of life and it's amazing
Kermit stop licking me so if you want to
get better if you want to be better
informed in a way that fits your routine
which this does because it's so easy and
convenient eh es que IMM comm slash
Jenna Julianne it is awesome it is very
helpful and you will find yourself just
thirsty for more information from the
skin so check it out and your inter
doing a $250 Visa gift card when you do
that and also lastly guys stitch fix up
your fashion game with the help of the
online personal styling professionals at
stitch fix they know what they're doing
you fill out a bunch of questions about
your style preferences clothing
preferences what you'd like to wear how
often you like to wear certain things
and a literal personal stylist will
handpick items that go along with your
profile and then they send it to you in
a box and you open the box you're like
dang I'm okay truly kept everything I
kept everything they send me some jeans
they send me the beautiful denim jacket
I love that denim jacket they send me a
couple of like there was like a thin
shirt but like with a hoodie oh I love
that it's really great and it's a cool
way to expand your wardrobe in ways that
you probably couldn't do by yourself and
it's nice that you have to go to the
store to shop so stitch fix handles it
for you you try them on at home
pressure you can try things on and see
how they fit or how you like them and
you only pay for what you love and then
you send it back shipping is on them and
there's no subscription required which
is really nice you can sign up to
receive scheduled shipments whenever you
want you make the subscription so check
it out by going to stitch fix that's STI
TCH fi XCOM and use a code oh sorry
stitch fixed comm slash Jenna Julianne
use could that URL to get extra 25% off
when you keep all the items in your box
check it out or lick hit the link in the
description down below if you don't want
to remember that but your sponsors but
yeah like I said it I think I like
watching those shows because it that's
you know my dream life is pretty rugged
and it just it makes me feel like home
your dream life is rugged yeah well
something more like Tom and mountain men
you know like you have your house and
like those people hunt I probably went
hot but not this I'm not judging anybody
for anything but like I wouldn't do that
but I would like to live you know in a
place where I could have some animals
yeah like a big farm a little more
remove like a cabin or something yeah
yeah it is nice I mean I I find
survivalist stuff like people who take
that seriously and study it very
interesting like some of the stuff that
they're talking about like this one guy
remember you're saying the guy from
Boston or Massachusetts much he heard
water like the sound of it at a certain
way and he knew it was drinking water oh
I learned that from Bear Grylls years
ago really yeah because remember that
show where they would just drop him in
the middle of [ __ ] wherever they're
gross you have to survive for like you
know the night or to date or however
long it would take him to like survive
which meant he was always looking for
listening for water and then looking for
any signs of like a road or something
like that and yeah pretty dope yeah not
as tough what do you think you would
excel at hmm
there's no gluten in the wild so you'd
be okay I mean like obviously if you're
in that situation your dietary
restrictions kind of go out there one
you just eat to survive that's like what
it is but I don't know I mean I feel
like what one thing I would excel at is
maybe being resourceful and I think
building a shelter I'd be pretty good at
I think I've watched enough of like
survivor and survivalist stuff to know
little basic tricks to to make things
happen but I feel like once I would be
out there I would be I would be more
resourceful than the average person with
the things I would find and stuff like
that where I would fail terribly is
night time and just being scared like a
little baby mm-hmm
because you know when we're in Big Bear
and I hear like a coyote that [ __ ]
freaks me out dude I grabbed all my
flashlights I put on all my sweaters you
know I'm scared
that should scary what are you not
scared of coyotes a pack of animals wild
animal surrounding you packs of coyotes
and wolves are some of the scariest I'd
say I'm less scared of a bear or or even
like a cat out in the wild
well yeah and in the Bears that you're
even like in Big Bear or around here or
like where I grew up
you know brown bears and black bears
like we used to go camping all the time
like it's something that you have an
understanding of like to scare them away
or that they're probably interested in
your food and that you shouldn't sleep
in the same clothes like your food
should be nowhere where you're sleeping
and your camp like basic things to avoid
that or what happens when you do see a
bear and you're just you know squeezed
together and try to make yourself seem
bigger and scare the bear away a lot of
those bears are skittish they don't they
don't really wanna like attack you yeah
yes they're like a grizzly bears [ __ ]
forget it like forget it
those yeah I'm terrified don't play by
the rules because they will attack you
and kill you yeah I'm all set with
grizzly bears yeah but like the pack
thing you know a pack of wolves will
kill you anywhere any place any time
like at least with the bear I mean even
if they're maybe six seven hundred
pounds that's like you know good luck
but yeah let's say like a like a bound
lion comes up to you a big ol non-line
yeah yes they could kill you and likely
would if they wanted to but in essence
it is a 1v1 right oh my god no I'm just
saying
right if they're gonna charge at you
that's one target okay so you have to
pay attention to it so be fair if a
mound lion or a cougar or a bobcat or
whatever the hell wants to attack you
it's gonna do it from behind like way
before you ever know maybe maybe more
[ __ ] silent ninjas in the night or
hitting your you spot it just in time to
turn around and it's a 1v1 no okay fine
okay fine fine
they're all perfect James Bond they
sneak up behind me you don't even hear
him fine
say that happens right they land a nice
little gash on my back no hold on no
just got his jaws right around your neck
no but say he misses cuz it is a 1v1
alright so he it's dark - how is he
seeing the dark there cat okay so maybe
he sees pretty well so let's just say he
didn't sink his teeth into my neck for
the first shot okay he grabs my arm my
back whatever my leg dude I turn around
I'm probably dead already I'm ready for
Julianne versus a bob i'm prolly dead
okay i'm there's a very very good chance
that you're like i haven't already bled
out i will do it very soon and probably
bleed out so fast that he won't even get
to like bite another part of my body but
in the in this scenario that i didn't i
get to see him i turn around
maybe i have my knife my my flashlight
they don't like flashlights i'm sure cuz
they're well yours actually can blind
pete my flashlights are [ __ ] gnarly
so i flash him in the eye you wouldn't
have a knife so let's talk about a real
life sighs I must have your flash nice I
don't know okay flashlight hmm all right
I have multiple flash if I'm in a
scenario where there's a mountain flash
mountain lion I have one headlamp and
multiple flashlights on me both are
which are pretty like they're they're
like rocks they're so solid they're like
right so I would pop on all my
flashlights thousand lumens to the eyes
and though the your arm is probably in
his mouth or so yeah probably yeah yeah
you're it's like listening to someone
that's like yeah do two five no no an
arc underwater punch a minute
okay what I did not say that I did not
say I punch a shark underwater in the
face have you ever tried to punch
underwater Julian no I'm saying that's
like what it's like listening to your
life self-defense plan here this is me
this is me playing devil's advocate and
only trying to say that there's a chance
whereas if you get surrounded by a pack
of wolves you might as well just like
say a prayer and say goodnight that's it
that's not true you have a chance to
fight no matter what fight or flight you
have a chance no one's arguing that you
don't have a chance against a cougar or
a puma or whatever it is like no of
course you have a chance Julian no one
said you don't have a chance so you're
saying there's a chance no tell me
you're okay they're a pack of wolves if
you have a rifle but you said I don't
know what what if the flashlight really
messes with them it's pot anything's
possible not saying you don't but if
you're unarmed you have nothing and
you're alone in the woods yeah your
chances aren't very good if you're just
in your house and you have a [ __ ]
rifle or you have one of those air horns
or like [ __ ] that really scares animals
yeah you have a much higher chance
I didn't anyone bring an air horn I'm
they do in season two oh they do well
they do give them bear spray and a flare
for like emergencies like that I was
thinking like some sort of item that
made a really loud noise would be nice
to have because they're always just like
a bear walks up to the milk hey bear go
away bear and the Bears like no no they
just keep walking towards them I gotta
go no no no no I'm blowing glass
no just the bear speak Spanish they
don't know what go away bear means well
we were in Big Bear one time and you
heard a bear and those weirdos scared
I've ever seen you know it wasn't dude
okay you know you don't need to just
like put me on PLAs okay we're sitting
outside okay I love you said you got
scared as if we both didn't scurry
inside their dogs and I go we need to go
inside right now in the house go we were
outside of the cabin at night like 2
a.m. probably we had been drinking
hanging out whatever
we go outside just to chill like look at
the Stars for a little bit before we go
to sleep and then like it wasn't like
rustling in the woods or like a bear
growl from from like you know distance
it was like it felt like it was in our
ear it was so close I don't even know
where they were probably only like the
corner of the cabin that we were sitting
at very close and it was just like the
deepest growl I had ever heard and we
you heard it too so I know I'm not crazy
and so we we both looked at each other a
long time yeah I was [ __ ] scared but
I I've been more scared my life I think
like that one time in my mind that I
came in front came confronted a mound
line and he he missed me on the first
one you asked me that okay let me tell
you where I think you would just check
your watch tunes and really it vibrated
let me tell you where I think you would
struggle me and Chris have that thing
where if we're all hanging out and the
girls are just like talking late at
night me and Chris or tires just look
each other like wow thank you for that
you know that I like aging with my
friends and having conversations oh so
you like I don't just sit around in
human meme with my buddies you know I do
and then I get tired at an appropriate
hour and then I took the time I think
that you would struggle oh here we go if
you were in a situation like alone let's
talk about alone right you need to you
said you would excel at building a
structure I think I would or a shelter
everything would I think you would
struggle when you have small failures
which there are many when you're doing
everything by yourself or outside you
would let them really get to you really
destroy your mood and you would get
[ __ ] pissed and angry and frustrated
and there's no one there to lift you out
of that dark deep hole that you've dug
for yourself
wow that was so exposing you get so
frustrated about some things and then it
just shuts you down and you just decide
it's not worth
but it's not my fault like today I was
trying to make a Crunchwrap I was trying
to do a perfect recreation of a country
mmm my stupid gluten-free tortillas kept
ripping everytime I folded them they
sure did
so yeah I'm pissed what the heck why
would I not be I know but like I was
trying to do my radio show and I'm there
and I'm just you know like do a show
you're gonna be like up and like
exciting you know and you're just [ __ ]
pissed like right next so pissed next to
me you're so mad just start like taking
other [ __ ] out on me and I'm like no no
Jay no no all right I take another [ __ ]
out I'm just like I'm I'm annoyed mm-hmm
I'm annoyed mm-hmm and then I'm like
what what would I do what I do it I'm
like I'm trying to like I'm not taking
things out I'm just I'm just but that's
how you take stuff out of me you'll say
something unrelated that's just like
whatever and I'm like okay yep mm-hmm
I'm sorry I'm sorry that's happening and
you're just like oh oh that was my
impression of you doing something else a
good impression of me I feel like
sometimes you don't always roll with the
punches fair as punch I start coming you
start punching the budget I start
punching the punches varies they're
rolling with the punches you just punch
the punches if things aren't going
absolutely can if things aren't going
your way you get real [ __ ] angry well
I yes yes hmm
because I want them to go man I would be
okay like if I'm trying to build a
structure and it's not going my way
okay let's problem-solve and make a
different kind of structure but I want
it to go my way I think that if you're
alone and you have to only rely on
yourself that attitude I think would
eventually be your demise it wouldn't be
that in hung small value just a new year
I knew you're straight-up hunger and you
just getting irrationally mad at
objects for whatever they did to you
sounds like I wouldn't do that well at
all actually it sounds like a mountain
lion would be far from my undoing
something how would you mind it I think
you would struggle at it but I think you
can get better you know cuz eventually
you'd be like well I'm hungry and if I
don't go do XY and Z regardless if I'll
mad at I am at my knife and that piece
of wood over there I gotta go make it
happen like you are a doer you know but
I think you would struggle with your
frustration and anger when things don't
go your way we think like mentally I
would struggle a little bit yeah mmm
emotionally at least I would hope that
at least I wouldn't drop my flint in the
water like that guy did oh that's good
to call oh yeah
what about survivor what would you be
good at oh god I genuinely think that if
I knew I was going on Survivor
I would I would kind of I don't know I
think I would own it the challenges I
think I would yeah I think I could do
well if those challenges I've watched a
lot of survivor with you and I think
from what I've seen maybe there's a
couple like a couple of ones that really
require shoulder dexterity no not for me
but I think for someone your age and of
athletic ability even if you were hungry
you would do like just fine you know
what I mean like more better than
average because they cast anybody in
everybody from all different kinds of
backgrounds yes my undoing would be the
social game when I'm hungry yeah you
would be totally fine at the athletic
challenges even if you are very hungry
you would excel yeah but I would suck
socially when I'm hungry for sure you
aren't so difficult to be around when
you're hungry have you got have you
grasped that yet audience from this
podcast just ask Rome Rome has to deal
with it too when we travel and you're
hungry oh my god yeah so what I'm hungry
I'm not that bad what I'm not okay
here's what I would do if he lost enough
challenges and I'm there's one guy on my
team who just just eat him you know he's
eating away at me just because he's
annoying and he's
doing anything and I'm ravenous and
depleted and hungry and [ __ ] that
would be my undoing I would do something
I wouldn't do anything drastic but I
would do something to where it would
jeopardize my position in the game
socially and I would get voted off
that's what would happen
hungry yeah I wouldn't I wouldn't I
wouldn't be the reason you know
physically that we lost I wouldn't you
know be just an outrageous person that
caused drama I would just be a really
frustrated hungry person that did
something that would get myself in
trouble yeah you like semi shut down
almost when you're hungry yeah I can't
be yet yeah we're tired yeah I know
patience for anybody I saw and that's
that's something that's a character flaw
I think I could be a lot better at that
than I am
I feel like one of the keys to success
on Survivor in particular is being a
non-confrontational person all the time
yeah so even when everyone is making you
crazy because you've lived with them for
30 days and you have to deal with
everyone's personality and some of them
are lying to you and backstabbing you
and you know playing the game as they
should because you signed up for it yeah
a lot of it is just avoiding all of the
confrontation that you would really like
to have and I something like just taking
the high road yeah I sometimes can be
very confrontational and I feel like at
one point one of those [ __ ]
would just tip me over and now it's time
for us to have a conversation and that
would first sure you know that's the
most accurate thing I think that would
really get me that is so on point like
something that no one else cares about
except for me and this one person and I
make it up into the biggest [ __ ] deal
in the whole world and I just cannot
stop telling them what they [ __ ] did
wrong and how it pissed me off and then
I'm voted out and then you might be
villainized to by the Edit editors you
never know like that no I'm serious
because all it takes is one person to a
snap once and then it's like okay what
are we yeah I feel like that would be my
undoing like some of the things that
happen I don't know how or even you know
when someone flips an alliance and the
next day they're just like no worries
man it's fine I feel like I'd be okay at
that for the most part but it's um
because I love the game yeah appreciate
you yeah you can yeah
but like some of the just like
interpersonal things going on and like
the girl that let the chickens go like
you know I was like your only choice
though is to just like vent to your
one-on-one camera time and then just
like not flip out and that's it
with that all said you're very good for
sure but like I do think you're also
good at compartmentalizing things and
and like living your life with these
issues that you're not dealing with
right in front of you you're just like
right I'll package that up and figure it
out later
you're good at that you're like one of
the best I've ever seen because I suck
at it well whatever happened that's
upsetting you you need to put it away so
you can go do what you need to do right
now yes you can just like wow lo when
you're like oh I'm so this is terrible
and no this is - yes yes and you're
mocking it and you're mocking it but
this is something shocking it no but I'm
saying like this you never I don't know
I feel like some people have they
struggle with that more than others and
you don't struggle with that no I did
and do sometimes and you've helped
wasn't mocking no I'm not saying you're
mocking me I wasn't at all but I'm
saying like you being with you and
spending time with you over the past
however many years we've been together
you have times you have taught me to
compartmentalize things and like that's
a very valuable skill in life just it is
and it's something that I was not good
at and I'm still not good at I'm getting
better right sometimes you just wear
like your emotions on your sleeve yes
and I think a lot of those emotions are
very hungry yes and I think a lot of
people also do that for a lot of
emotions they like they can't quite
function knowing that there's something
that isn't worked out mm-hmm right and
that's that's a learned skill it really
is so I think that's one of those things
that a lot of people on Survivor they if
for the first time they're like [ __ ]
maybe I have to deal with this later
maybe I have to really just like put
this put this away right now so I think
you you knowing how to do that already
is a huge advantage but yeah all it
would take is he really having it one
person oh you're pissing me off and then
I just really go off you go off on a
Virgo style like you really just break
them it's done like I say I have the
sharpest tongue when I'm mad like I will
just say the most hurtful
can [ __ ] because I'm ready to just give
it to you you've been stewing and
stewing and stewing and you've pushed me
to my [ __ ] edge and now I'm gonna
tell you the cold hard painful truth you
Beach and now you didn't want to hear it
and I'm so [ __ ] sorry but that's it
and then everyone's like woah say that
and then I go where's the line and then
I'm voted out yeah I would watch that
season as [ __ ] hmm I mean in an
alternate universe simulation I would
love to see you on Survivor I wouldn't
do it now you wouldn't know even our
real circumstances yeah but in an
alternate universe or a simulation I
would love to watch you on Survivor I
think at some point we'll be able to do
that probably plug you into a simulation
when watching either you know or even
just spectator I want survive with the
video game is that a thing VR but
there's way too many complicated things
that you could do well it would have to
be no NPCs it has to be all other
players you see like your chocolate
survivor survivor via our chat serve our
survivors that survive er serve our chat
will agree on the name later but you
take out all the hunger and all those
survival you're doing it that way or you
have such an immersive VR experience
that you do feel hungry you have to take
a pill before you log on the game and
that simulates again hunger mmm trust me
they tested it on five people three of
them died before fun tight you haven't
watched that much alone though you
should watch more why keep falling
asleep it's really started at 2:00 a.m.
what am I supposed to do I like to watch
things at night okay
me too I am so tired at night what a
concept you're tired at night long day
it's nighttime time to not sleep you
need new bed we can't do it I
I love the late nights where I don't
have to wake up in the morning for
anything you know I can sleep in and I
have a decent amount of energy when we
get in bed and I'm like let's watch some
TV and I like we really cranked out Mike
episode after episode and we're having
fun I think it's snack that's fun of me
but that's like maybe once a week maybe
if I can handle it
most times it's like all right loans on
ok for second no my favorite show he'll
be like too far ahead I'm like you're
gonna fall asleep in 3 2 okay so now I
can't even watch five minutes of the
show yeah but you clearly don't struggle
too hard with that dilemma because you
do watch far ahead yeah I do because if
I if I had abided by all of these rules
of you being like don't watch ahead I
would have watched nothing ever ever
okay you know to be fair I would never
watch a game like our a show like
Westworld or like Game of Thrones like I
wouldn't I wouldn't watch that stuff
without you
but yeah I'm gonna [ __ ] I'm gonna
watch some alone before I fall asleep
because you knocked out the second your
head hit the pillow because you have a
gift from God is it again do that yeah
it is
I think it's a curse people have a
really hard time falling asleep I think
it's it's a blessing curse because I'm
not that way like I'm so comfortable in
our bed with you no I'm serious like in
my situation no stay together we're just
friends okay okay okay in my cot off to
the side of your bed I feel very
comfortable but like in a hotel
I suck at sleeping every time I would go
in last-minute trips I sucked at
sleeping I hate it I slept three hours
maybe every time and I would have to
listen to the sleep with me podcast to
fall asleep so it's like yeah I have to
be in my nest after you my safety spot
otherwise I can't sleep for [ __ ] so I
know what the feeling is like I'm not
being able to sleep I just don't get it
at home yeah okay you want to watch them
alone real quick yeah I'm gonna just lay
here okay can i babe goodnight this is
actually a nightmare I've had like I
fall asleep while I'm live and then I'm
wake up I'm like oh my god I fall asleep
well I was like even though we're not a
lot but you know what I mean mm-hmm
so I get stressed dream
yeah baby
Peter says the podcast is over you
should just set up with my lap all right
well peachy called it it's not over to
the little lady sings and she's just
saying I'm like a little time we're down
there yeah that's cute
well actually let's do a dual shout out
to our favorite content on the internet
Daniel reffing amazes that fair amazing
link him he just released a peachy song
he's been making songs about the dogs
about us and either also incredible and
he's just so talented so give it a
listen give it a watch down below he did
the PG song what is it called it's
something something real cute but it's
it's it's adorable so check it out
that's like our favorite thing this week
absolutely also I do want to say a lot
of you and this is our fault but a lot
of you were like where the [ __ ] the
podcast this week a lot of you and
twitch chat on Twitter just everywhere
where the [ __ ] podcast and it's
partially our fault because we didn't
explicitly say next week is Julian's
birthday we're not gonna apologize so
many games had a lot yeah we had a lot
of [ __ ] I think we were recording with
Debbie we couldn't think of it so I want
to say thank you for your patience and
sorry we did that and here's another
advanced warning okay there is a week at
the beginning of May I don't hear the
exact date maybe May first or something
the week of May first that Monday no
podcast we were taking our first
vacation ever
and we're never taken a vacation we were
leaving town leaving work and we are
going far far far far not that far away
far away we may 6th there'll be no
podcast right you're right it is May 6th
May 6th no podcast we will be out of
town on vacation so mark your calendars
and when that Monday comes don't be
wondering where we are because we are on
vacation from everything from everything
we're we were really doing it up but
thank you guys for hanging out for
another episode
and that's Kermit's tail
yeah see you next see you guys bye
[Music]